steve levy mr monday night he had the
call last night
in denver with the broncos and the
titans made his uh debut as the main
play-by-play voice with
brian griese and louis riddick he'll be
on the call for drew brees and the
saints
at the las vegas raiders next monday
night so how did it feel leaves
that was a classic game dan they're
going to be replaying that game for
years to come
uh it was fun it was fun in the booth we
had a good time
i think uh i think was a good jumping
off point for us you know
uh we'll be much better next week and
and hope to be much better uh every
every single week but it
it felt great to finally get it going
you know there's been so much talk about
you know the monday football booth
really and uh just good to call some
football
did you read twitter at all uh i have
not you know i can't get some text
messages so
uh i'll tell you what it does it does
make you feel about
pretty good about yourself dan it makes
you feel like you know you know maybe
i'm a decent human being i can't tell
you how many people
and yourself included have reached out
with you know with kind tweets uh kind
texts throughout the some tweets but
mostly texts
uh throughout the process you know
leading up to getting the gig and then
uh you know wishing good luck and relax
and have a good time and all those kind
of important reminders but
it's really been great for my my friends
and my family and uh it's really
appreciated
but has it set in i mean you're calling
monday night football
so that's a great question so not really
like uh you know last night i did last
night what i did
one year ago we had that same back end
of the doubleheader
uh the opening night weekend it was the
broncos again
uh so not really you know there wasn't a
massive pregame show and the massive
hype we knew we were on late so we'd
lose some part of the country
um and like that so i think it really
kicks in
uh this coming monday night uh we'll
have the stage to ourselves
and uh we'll be on at the normal time
it'll be the full pregame
uh it's also the actual 50th anniversary
of uh the first ever monday night
football game and then i think you know
listen
quite frankly we want to ramp up here
dan we want to be at our best for week
three
uh we know we'll have a few eyeballs on
that one and i think you know honestly
that's probably the best regular season
game on the schedule certainly on paper
you know things can change throughout
the season before the season starts
if you can only watch one nfl game i'm
guessing a lot of people would pick
kansas city
at baltimore and we're fortunate to have
that on the schedule how nervous were
you
yeah again not really um and i i think
that's part of being over prepared you
know people talk about that if
you're if you're properly prepared you
shouldn't be nervous and again having
the experience
of doing the game a year ago uh really
went a long way towards that i can't
tell you and you get this but i hope
everybody does
uh we have so much help dan we get we
get
so much help from so many different from
people
uh you know from the people who are
working in the booth they they were
drilling like it was you know a home
depot
store last night trying to make
adjustments in the booth so it's our
first time with the crew and you know
and greasy wants his telestrator here
and riddick needs this over there and i
need a shelf
you know and it's too cold for for
riddick it's too hot for me in the booth
you know
it's just i'm just saying like there's
so many people running around and even
and that's even when it's it's part
paired down because of the pandemic
we're probably traveling half the people
and then the influx of emails i've never
seen anything like it the amount of
information but again it's it's just
people trying to be helpful and it's not
just espn
information people it's really it's the
nfl it's uh it's the two clubs
uh they're public relations people
everybody's trying to be so helpful give
you everything you need
uh to put the best product on the air so
it's it's been a lot of fun man
what about no fans in the stands
so you know i found uh at one point i
said listen to the crowd you know it's
not here you know
and uh in the headset the mix we're
getting
i think is very different than what is
being played in the stadium
uh and if you if you get lost in the
moment and i hope this is the case at
home
but if you get lost in the moment like i
was broadcasting the game you hear the
crowd roar and they seem to
roar at the right time and uh you know
i'll go back and watch the tape
and see how it sounded on television but
um
you know i'm looking forward to crowds
you know sort of building the head
at least the soldiers had a funny report
they had 500 people in the stadium last
night
and we were really told it was kind of a
test to test the protocols
sort of a dry run they're going to have
5700 in denver for their next home game
in a couple of weeks
when brady and the bucks come to town
but uh you know so
in essence they're testing you know
they're testing it out on the friends of
the family
the players and the uh and the employees
of the
team but the concession stands were open
and those kinds of things couldn't
really hear that crowd but
the crowd the the enhanced audio that
was piped in certainly in my headset
uh made it sound good and i think you
could get lost in the moment which was
nice
steve levy the he's mister monday night
you're no longer sportscenter
anchor right yeah i'm still not i'm
still not used to my my twitter bio is
going to stay as the
unofficial voice of the bahamas bowl but
but you don't do sportscenter anymore
uh not during the not during the nfl
season i would think so
you know i'll see you i'll see you
january 7th dan i know you're missing me
on the 11 o'clock show
i'll come back and do a sports center
with you lise
it's late dan i don't know sometimes you
know we go after van pelt then it's you
know
it's 12 30 or something it's a you know
there's a mariners game that goes a
little later
oh that used to drive me crazy when you
go okay just close this out
come on in and let's go and then
somebody would give up a three-run jack
and you go oh
god that goes 16 innings
i remember back in the day we'd like
let's just put our voice down on a track
and say and that led to the final score
you know and of course not thinking for
the poor people who have to stay behind
and put the video to the audio and all
that i remember
there was a sunday night and mike keenan
mike keenan got
fired i think in st louis does that
sound right and
well you got fired a lot of places it
did but keith oberman had already gone
home
and so i was i was there
and then i was getting ready to leave
and all of a sudden it came over the
wire
hey mike keenan just got fired we had to
redo
like the first block of sportscenter and
uh
the joke was that we sent judd birch
to oberman's house and that keith was in
the hot tub
which which wasn't true but we created
this story
that you got to go get oberman and bring
him back and then we had to go and redo
the
first 15 minutes of sportscenter that
night uh
the great memories damn shame that we
didn't have zoom back then because then
you could have had keith in the hot tub
in that first time are you following the
uh stanley cup final here
you know a little bit uh very very
surprised with the dallas stars i mean
did not see that coming
uh good for them and you know i kind of
feel bad for whoever
you know it looks like tampa is you know
the class i think of the teams remaining
but you know whatever's going to win
this stanley cup is
you know there's no asterisk or anything
as far as that's concerned but i feel
for the for the players the organization
their fans that they won't have that
that traditional celebration and i'm
sure whenever there are fans allowed
back in the building
uh you know they'll reenact it and let
the guys come out skate around the
stanley cup but it won't be the same
thing
um but the nhl has done a great job in
the television product like i said
you know the nba too by the way in wnbc
like you can get lost in the game if
you're sitting at home
i i find if you're interested in the
game you can get lost in
it and you don't then realize hey there
are no fans there
and the enhanced crowd and all that so i
really think you know all the tv folks
have done a really good job
of bringing that product home as best
they can under extraordinary
circumstances really
tough doing tough for doing an nfl game
or a hockey game
that's a good question um you know it's
funny
i think there's so much more that goes
into the nfl game there's so many you
know
in terms of the cameras the amount of
people in the headset and and certainly
amount of the eyeballs that are watching
and the viewers i thought you're going
to ask me tougher
college or pro and uh i mean there's no
there's no question to me the nfl is an
easier game to broadcast
by virtue of they're just half the
players i mean start right there
and it's uh you know college plays like
an extra quarter the game's like an
extra 40 minutes
the nfl game flew pretty quick we had a
really fast first half and
you do look up and you see hey there's a
minute left in the first quarter
uh the nfl is so pat is packaged so well
for television you know to try to fit in
that three-hour window so
um i would say hockey's a little easier
for me but the pressure's kind of off
you know
there's no spotter you're not relying on
anyone else in hockey
because there's no time to look down and
get help you're sort of on your own that
way
and uh and the game just flies and it
seems to be you know hockey's a little
more under the radar
uh the whole world's not watching it's
really you know hockey fans i think
and as passionate as they are um they're
a good bunch too maybe a little less
critical
i almost text you last night when you
said stephen goskowski a future hall of
famer
all right let's let's talk about that
you do you think that's all face or is
that
he was a hall of famer before last night
he's hall of very good
oh dad i
i think i mean you know a lot of this is
statistically
based yeah he's got every number i i
think he's a hall of fame kicker
how many kickers do we have at the hall
of fame by the way john stenerood
is uh uh benatari's going in morton
anderson's in
yeah yes that's right yep ray guy is a
punter but i
i they're it's really tough to get in it
no you're right you're right but but if
anybody you know uh
guskowski's numbers are off the charts
uh
you know he has more points i think his
accuracy level might be more than
vinitari
again his his career percentage went way
down last night
i know it did that's hard to do you know
what
goskowski is going to have you induct
him i think if he makes it into the hall
of fame
yeah i should you're right again
so that's that's a rough night and uh
you know we hopped on it a little bit
but
you know titans kicked i think eight
field goals all of last season
eight field goals the entire season and
still made it to the conference
championship game
they were a half away from the super
bowl you know so
they got to figure that out mike brabel
should have never been in that spot last
night
you know 47 in the nfl in altitude is a
chippy and that you know
that was his longest kick last night so
that that game shouldn't have been close
that was that was 10 points you know
off the board for tennessee that should
have been there so i think they were
fortunate to escape with that you know
uh post-game beers last night uh two two
bud lights that's my thing
like two bud lights that was it that'll
be cool by yourself
uh some of the fellas socially distanced
of course of course drinking through the
mask
yes which is not an easy trick you know
you take the loop off your ear take a
step put the loop back on your ear
very enjoyable there oh you don't get
cheated do you hey uh safe travels
and uh we'll be watching next week and
uh i didn't want i
i knew it was your first game and i
didn't want to text you anything i just
thought you know what let me
but when you said that i go i was just
gonna go hall of
hof question mark but i thought nah
i i didn't i didn't want confusion and i
would have been unprofessional in doing
something like that
no you can't be a professional i i take
uh i'll take your text anytime brother
all right buddy
safe travels thank you leaves that's uh
steve leafy mr monday night
and he's got the raiders against the
saints coming up